hey folks in this video i want to show
you something pretty interesting about
these lagrange multipliers that we've
been studying uh so the first portion
i'm just going to kind of get the setup
which is a lot of review from what we've
seen already but i think you're really
going to like where this is going in the
end
so one of the examples i showed and i
think this is a pretty nice prototypical
example for constrained optimization
problems is that you're running a
company and you have some kind of
revenue function
that's dependent on various choices you
make in running the company and i think
i said the number of hours of labor you
employ and the number of tons of steel
you use you know if you are
manufacturing something metallic
and you know this might be modeled as
some multi-variable function of h and s
right now we don't really care about the
specifics and you're trying to maximize
this right that's kind of the whole
point of this unit that we've been doing
is that you're trying to maximize some
function but you have a constraint this
is the real world you can't just spend
infinite money you have some kind of
budget some sort of amount of money you
spend as a function of those same
choices you make the hours of labor you
employ the tons of steel you use and
this again it's going to equal some
multi-variable function that tells you
you know how much money you spend for a
given amount of hours and given number
of
tons of steel
and you set this equal to some constant
this tells you the amount of money
you're willing to spend
and our goal has been to maximize some
function subject to a constraint like
this and the mental model you have in
mind is that you're looking in the input
space inside the xy plane or i guess
really it's the hs plane in this case
right your inputs are h and s and points
in this plane tell you possible choices
you can make for hours of labor and tons
of steel
and you think of this budget
as some kind of curve
in that plane right all the sets of h
and s that equal ten thousand dollars is
going to give you some kind of curve
and the core value we care about is that
when you maximize this revenue you know
when you set it equal to a constant i'm
going to call m star that's like the
maximum possible revenue that's going to
give you a contour that's just barely
tangent to the constraint curve
and if that seems unfamiliar definitely
take a look at the videos preceding this
one
but just to kind of continue the review
this gave us the really nice property
that you look at the gradient vector
for the thing you're trying to maximize
r
and that's going to be proportional to
the gradient vector
for the constraint function for this
this b so gradient of b
and this is because gradients are
perpendicular to contour lines again
this should feel mostly like review at
this point so the core idea was that we
take this gradient of r
and then make it proportional with some
kind of proportionality constant lambda
to the gradient of b to the gradient of
the constraint function
and up till this point this value lambda
has been wholly uninteresting it's just
been a proportionality constant right
because we couldn't guarantee that the
gradient of r is equal to the gradient
of b all we care about is that they're
pointing in the same direction so we
just had this constant sitting here and
all we really said is make sure it's not
zero
but here we're going to get to where
this little guy actually matters
so if you'll remember in the last video
i introduced this function called the
lagrangian
the lagrangian and it takes in multiple
inputs they'll be the same inputs that
you have for your budget function and
your revenue function or more generally
the constraint and the thing you're
trying to maximize it takes in those
same variables but also as another one
of its inputs
it takes in lambda
so it is a higher dimensional function
than both of these two because we've got
this extra lambda and the way it's
defined looks a little strange at first
it just seems kind of like this random
hodgepodge of functions that we're
putting together
but last time i kind of walked through
why this makes sense you take the thing
you're trying to maximize and you
subtract off this lambda
multiplied by the constraint function
which is b
of those inputs
minus and then whatever this constant is
here right i'm going to give it a name
i'm going to call this constant
lowercase b so maybe we're thinking of
it as ten thousand dollars but it's
whatever your actual budget is
so we think of that and i'm just going
to emphasize here that that's a constant
right
that this b is being treated as a
constant right now you know we're
thinking of h and s and lambda all as
these variables
and this gives us some multivariable
function
and if you'll remember from the last
video
uh the reason for defining this function
is it gives us a really nice compact way
to solve the constrained
optimization problem you set the
gradient of l
equal to zero or really the zero vector
right it'll be a vector with three
components here
and when you do that you'll find some
solution where you'll find some solution
which i'll call h star
s star
and lambda i'll give it that green
lambda color
lambda
star
you'll find some value that when you
input this into the function the
gradient will equal zero
and of course you might find multiple of
these right you might find multiple
solutions to this problem but what you
do is for each one of them you're going
to take the take a look at h star and s
star then you're going to plug those
into the revenue function or the thing
that you're trying to maximize and
typically you only get a handful you get
a number that you could actually plug
each one of them into the revenue
function and you'll just check which one
of them makes this function the highest
and whatever the highest value this
function can achieve that is m star that
is the maximum possible revenue subject
to this budget
but it's interesting that when you solve
this you get some specific value of
lambda right there is a specific lambda
star that will be associated with this
solution and like i said this turns out
not to just be some dummy variable it's
going to carry information about how
much we can increase the revenue if we
increase that budget
and here let me show you what i mean so
we've got this m star
and i'll just write it again
m star here and what that equals i'm
saying that's the maximum possible
revenue so that's going to be the
revenue when you evaluate it at h star
h star and s star
and h star and s star they are whatever
the solution to this
gradient of the lagrangian equals 0
equation is right you you set this
multivariable function equal to the zero
vector you solve when each of its
partial derivatives equal zero and
you'll get some kind of solution so when
you plug that solution in the revenue
that gives you the maximum possible
revenue
but what we could do is consider this as
a function of the budget
now this is the kind of thing that looks
a little bit wacky if you're just
looking at the formulas
but if you actually think about what it
means in this context of kind of a
revenue and a budget i think it's
actually pretty sensible where really if
we consider this b no longer to be
constant but something that you could
change right you're wondering well what
if i had a twenty thousand dollar budget
or what if i had a fifteen thousand
dollar budget you wanna ask the question
what happens as you change this b
well the maximizing value h star and s
star each one of those guys is going to
depend on b
right as you change what this constant
is it's going to change the values at
which the gradient of the lagrangian
equals 0.
so
i'm going to rewrite this function
as
the revenue evaluated at h star and s
star but now i'm going to consider that
h star and s star each as functions of b
right because they depend on it in some
way as you change b it changes the
solution to this problem it's very
implicit and it's kind of hard to think
about right it's hard to think okay as i
change this b how much does that change
h-star well that depends on what the you
know what the definition of r was and
everything there but in principle in
this context i think it's quite
intuitive you have a maximum possible
revenue and that depends on what your
budget is
so
what turns out to be a beautiful
absolutely beautiful magical fact
is that this lambda star
is equal to the derivative
of m star
the derivative
of this maximum possible revenue
with respect to b with respect to the
budget
and let me just show you what that
actually means right so if for example
let's say you did all of your
calculations and it turned out that
lambda star was equal to
2.3
you know previously that just seemed
like some dummy number that you ignore
and you just look at whatever the
associated values here are but if you
plug this in the computer and you see
lambda star equals 2.3 what that means
is for a tiny change in budget like
let's say your budget increases from ten
thousand to
ten thousand and one it goes up to ten
thousand
and one dollars you increase your budget
by just a little bit a little db
then the ratio of the change in the
maximizing revenue to that db is about
2.3
so what that would mean is increasing
your budget by a dollar
is going to increase m star over here it
would mean that m star
increases by about
you know two dollars and 30 cents
for every dollar that you increase your
budget and that's information you'd want
to know right if you see that this
lambda star is a number bigger than one
you'd say hey maybe we should increase
our budget we increase it from ten
thousand dollars to ten thousand one and
we're making more money so maybe as long
as lambda star is greater than one you
should keep doing whatever it takes to
increase that budget
so this fact is quite surprising i think
and it seems like it totally comes out
of nowhere so what i'm going to do in
the next video is prove this to you is
prove why this is true why this lambda
star value happens to be the rate of
change for the maximum value of the
thing we're trying to maximize with
respect to this constant with respect to
whatever constant you set your
constraint function equal to for right
now though i just want you to kind of
try to sit back and digest what this
means in the context of this specific
economic example and even if you never
looked into the proof and never
understood it there i think this is an
interesting and even useful tidbit of
knowledge to have about lagrange
multipliers
so with that i'll see you next video